melvin gordon not quite in the category
of superstar running back like saquon
barkley and ezekiel elliott but he has
taken a stand and he has held out of
charges training camp and the comments
from philip rivers that we love melvin
gordon but running back is a very deep
position for us that's a little close to
the line if not over the line when it
comes to getting between a guy and his
money melvin gordon is staying away to
get paid
and you know if dak prescott were to say
that about ezekiel elliott that would be
a problem for the cowboys and i think
for pretty much any other team that
would be a problem you have to wonder
what kind of a problem it is for the
chargers or is it calculated because the
bottom line is this i think melvin
gordon is over playing his hand i think
you have to be a special running back to
take the kind of position that gordon is
taking because i don't see an easy way
out of this for him well he could be the
next maurice jones drew who held out all
of training camp in the preseason in
2012 and eventually caved and showed up
when it was time to to earn regular
season game checks so i and and maybe
gordon is determined to sit out as long
as he possibly can maybe he'll sit out
10 weeks of the regular season and then
show up and get credit for this contract
year and then become a free agent next
year but i i even if he does
is he going to get on the open market
what he thinks he's worth has he
overvalued himself i really am concerned
as much as i support a guy who takes a
stand i've got serious concerns that
melvin gordon may not be the right guy
to be taking this stand and we'll see
what kind of blowback there is toward
philip rivers for saying what he said
remember when baker mayfield made the
comments about duke johnson in june
that reportedly sparked
mayfield being
approached by veteran players who didn't
like the fact that mayfield got in the
way of duke johnson trying to get what
he wants which is a one-way ticket out
of cleveland so you know rivers has the
experience he's got the the years and
he's got the incentive to try to get the
best possible team on the field because
he's running out of chances to win a
super bowl and if this if this is
calculated to get melvin gordon to show
up then you know maybe rivers gets a
pass on this one because time is of the
essence for him as he gets closer and
closer to the end of his career
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports